a lot of people the first grief that
they're going to feel will be parents
passing perhaps or dogs or friends what
have you learned about the process of
grief your best friend when he dies or
do you think he's going to want you
moping around for the rest of your life
feeling sorry for yourself and
complaining that your best friend just
died or do you think he wants you to
live your life to the fullest if he's a
good friend then he doesn't want you
moping around forever he wants you to
live your life to the fullest because he
can't anymore everything passes It's
Gonna Hurt there's no way to get around
it I think a lot of people feel a lot of
guilt everybody groups different you
have to know that it's going to pass and
when it does pass you have to be okay
you know that it has passed especially
with some of the losses that vets take
you guys were fighting for something
over there we all were we were fighting
for Freedom so you need to come home and
honor the sacrifice that that person
made and live your life to the fullest
know that they're smiling down on you